new in theaters this weekend chef and
men in black international what will you
see this is your weekend ticket
[Music]
hi I'm just I'm looking for a chair
mm-hmm who's asking John chef jr. do
your son my son jr. Sammy al Jackson his
back his shaft in shaft this weekend in
the sequel to the 2013 Samuel Jackson
his shaft I hope you're keeping up John
chef jr. shows up at his door asking for
help finding who killed his friend the
mismatched duo team up and antics ensue
as jr. is a straight-laced FBI agent and
shaft is one bad mother-- kitchen Mouse
I can't swear on this show you know they
say that cash shed is a bad mother ship
now
ignore him thinks he's a black James
Bond that dude was real you think it was
me chef runs into his ax juniors mother
as well as chefs own father the man
himself Richard Roundtree the original
chef from the original movies and TV
show from the 1970s on jab me with the
release of this movie the shaft
franchise has now spent 48 years and the
movie includes three generations of
chefs this movies for you if you're
looking for an action comedy this
weekend you're a fan of any of the
previous chef films or you counted how
many times I said shaft in this video
it's more than three oui
recognizable only as deja vu you look
right here
dismissed just as quickly
we are the best-kept secret in the
galaxy I want in the fourth installment
and the Men in Black franchise men and
black international comes out this
weekend in this spin-off of the original
trilogy a young woman played by Tessa
Thompson spies on and infiltrates the
MIB hoping to be enlisted you race my
parents memories but you didn't get mine
took me 20 years to find you how many
people can say that I found you after a
little convincing she suited up given
the name agent M and is shipped off to
the international branch come on well
it's not gonna save itself I'm driving
that really should be here expect to see
some of your favorite familiar gadgets
aliens and characters but don't expect
to see Will Smith or Tommy Lee Jones as
this is an all new spin-off story with
some new gadgets new aliens and new
locations like Morocco Italy and London
and then Black has been compromised
don't trust no one
ah the men in black the men and women in
black yeah perfectly good this one is
for you if you're a fan of the men in
black series you want to see what aliens
they come up with this time or you
already saw it and someone flashed you
with a neuralyzer and erased your memory
yeah Samuel Jackson is back his shaft
and shaft this weekend in this sequel to
the 2000 that is your weekend ticket
what will you see and check back next
week to see your toys come to life in a
fun way but also a terrifying way
[Music]